the retail and fashion industries are
being hit hard by the corona virus
pandemic millions of Americans rely on
it for their livelihood and the new
research indicates or predicts rather
global sales in the two and a half
trillion dollar industry will drop up to
30% it also expects a large number of
global fashion companies to go bankrupt
in the next 18 months vogue
editor-in-chief Anna Wintour and fashion
director Tom Ford have teamed up to help
those affected in the u.s. they created
a fundraising initiative it's called a
common thread our rule with a common
thread is not only to highlight all of
the designers whom you know and love
would also focus on those individuals
who keep our industry running the
challenges that we face a profound but
this fun we hope is a step in the right
direction only on CBS this morning Anna
Wintour shares how the CFDA vogue
fashion fund created as a response to
9/11 is being repurposed for this crisis
too it's already raised more than three
million dollars Anna I keep saying we
are all forever change by this but let's
let's focus specifically on the fashion
industry yes when we say fashion
industry it is so much more than the
clothes that we wear or going to a
designer store it's much bigger than
that absolutely I mean obviously behind
every designer seamstresses pattern
makers embroiderers there's a whole
support system when we were talking to
Senator Schumer and Senator Gillibrand
about the bailout for big businesses and
small businesses we came up with a
number that the support system for the
fashion industry equals 53 million jobs
let's let that sink in for a second
because I think when most people think
of the fashion industry they think hoity
and toity and certainly doesn't apply to
me and that's just not true is it
oh it applies to everybody and we are a
community and that is really what the
little videos that we we have our
vámanos CFDA talking about I'm a pattern
maker at branding Maxwell and the
assistant to the fashion designer
Alexander way I'm the press manager at
area we don't have you know this huge
financial backer that's going to help us
through this we just have our community
and our customers and they're hurting
just as much as we are right now it's
this enormous part of our economy that
is being decimated right now and why we
decided at the CFDA and boat to come
together and really try and do something
to help the way we did after September
the 11th when we launched the vogue CFDA
fashion fun we decided that we would
repurpose that gale to help the small
businesses and the small designers
within our community because they are
the future generation of American
fashion we were so lucky to be given an
inaugural grant of a million dollars by
Ralph Lauren himself I literally I burst
into tears I mean I just couldn't
believe the generosity we talked about
small business and brands that will
probably be the hardest hit at this
particular time are you worried about
the new voices in fashion being left out
it was really really the reason that we
launched or repurposed a fashion event
into a common thread we're going to be
giving out what we call micro loans like
5 10 15 20 up to $100,000 just to try
and help the ones that we feel need it
the most so that they can get through
these next few months and be able to
survive this has certainly been a
pandemic of numbers and I want to throw
this out of you it says a new report
says 80% of publicly listed fashion
companies in Europe and North America
will be in huge financial distress do
you ever think this industry can go back
to normal we are actually hosting though
global conversations next week over a
four-day period where we are going to
talk about the future of the runway show
we're going to talk about the future of
e-commerce a future creativity in the
future of retail because there's no way
we're going back to the way things were
I think you know a lot of us were
talking a lot about sustainability in
the
we were all flying so much and the shows
were so big and so expansion expensive
and these issues these really important
issues have been thrust upon us in a
much more significant and immediate way
and these are questions that everybody
is asking them you shared the story
about your son who was really one of the
people on the front lines though so
proud of my son he's a doctor and he is
right back in the emergency room and the
covered wards right now and because he
was sick for a while wasn't he was
pretty six I'm sure you've heard from
from many others that so many doctors
and so many nurses you know got sick but
he was once he was able determined to go
right back in and help and do everything
he can and thank goodness that we have
Governor Cuomo helping us through this
because you feel he's telling us the
truth
he's compassionate I think that we have
somebody in New York who he's a true
leader how are you handling quarantine
II do you have a ritual do you have a
routine for instance are you dressed
right now on the forest dressed as I am
every day but I you have on pants Anna
Wintour I am wearing a sweater I'm
getting ready to work out and I was
wondering what Anna was going to wear
because listen you always look
impeccable your hair is done did you do
your own hair today your David I did it
looks good it looks good
anybody who knows anna says she loves to
play she loves to laugh so I'll say this
I'll put on my glasses if you'll take
off yours absolutely deal nice to see
you Anna Wintour I see you to go thank
you for having me